[Música]
el maya el título del documental magher
mi guerra hace referencia al hecho de
que los personajes se apropiaron de una
guerra que no era de ellos era la guerra
de alguien más en un principio era la
guerra a la que los kurdos fueron
obligados a participar pero
posteriormente fue la guerra de todos
aquellos que no tenían nada que ver con
esa situación y que participaron igual
no estaban pagados nadie los obligó se
trata de un proceso personal en cada uno
de los personajes lo hicieron ya sea
para satisfacer una necesidad de
adrenalina o simplemente porque la
guerra es lo que siempre han hecho
los personajes de mi documental cuando
veían las imágenes del grupo armado
estado islámico abusando de niños y de
mujeres se dijeron no puedo quedarme sin
hacer nada tengo que ayudar ahora bien
entre la idea que tenían de lo que
podrían hacer antes de ir a esa guerra y
la realidad hay un mundo de diferencia
paula bovina y el drama alma
[Música]